pour se protéger continuer à servir
leurs clients
les pharmaciens prennent toutes les
précautions des gants des masques et
parfois des blues et de nombreuses
officines ont par ailleurs installé des
protections en plexiglas au niveau du
comptoir distanciation sociale oblige
les entrées dans les pharmacies se font
au compte-gouttes et les patients plus
rares alors depuis le début de la peur
du confinement
il ya quand même une baisse d'activité
qui est le témoin que les gens
respectent bien le confinement et c'est
une très bonne chose
on a simplement les gens du quartier qui
viennent nourrir leurs prescriptions ou
des gens qui viennent me demander des
produits comme des masques des jets de
riz coliques égaux mais les pharmaciens
ne peuvent satisfaire tous les clients à
la recherche de masques de protection
un produit essentiel dans la lutte
contre le coc vie 19 réservés en
priorité à ceux qui sont envoyés au
front en première ligne on a beaucoup de
demandes de masques qu'on ne peut pas du
tout n'aurait pas ce que c'est pour
l'instant un décret nous l'interdît
c'est parce qu'il manque des masques
pour les professionnels de santé
du coup il est interdit de vendre ou
donner des masques
à ce jour la majorité des gens qui ont
commencé à comprendre certaines
personnes ne comprennent pas mais le
fait est qu'il n'ya pas assez de masques
pour l'instant et du tout le but et du
coup le confinement fait qu'ils ont en
fait ils n'ont pas besoin d'autant de
masques que ceux qui pensent en fait pas
un besoin essentiel pour des personnes
confinées mais il est parfois compliqué
de le faire comprendre à des clients
inquiets voire agressif l'au delà de la
peur je pense que c'est aussi des gens
qui sépare une critique mais peut-être
qu'ils gèrent mal leur stress comme tout
le monde
et du coup il ya tellement beaucoup
d'informations dans tous les sens ils
ont du mal à faire la part des choses et
donc oui clairement ça prend le dessus
et
ils oublient parfois de rester polis on
en a beaucoup quand même mais plusieurs
par jour
il y en a beaucoup après il faut essayer
justement de rester calme parce que il y
en a vraiment tout le temps donc si on
commençait à se disputer les caisses et
c'est sans fin faute de mieux les
français les et sortent avec un bandana
un foulard ou une écharpe en période de
guerre et de pénurie de masques que
toutes les idées sont bonnes pour
certains ont pu le faire soi-même en
tissu et ensuite à l'intérieur il faut
absolument mettre beaucoup c est la
meilleure façon de trouver des lentilles
c'est celle d'utiliser du papier cuisson
pourquoi le papier cuisson parce que le
virus y résistent jusqu'à 60 degrés à
masquer devenu aujourd'hui l'objet de
toutes les convoitises à travers le
monde
les professionnels de santé doivent
lutter contre la plus grande crise
sanitaire de notre époque selon
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
avec un stock quasiment nulle en france
urgentiste infirmiers aides soignants
médecins libéraux et personnels des
ehpad sont envoyés au combat sans armes
ou presque